it's almost Halloween time did on a
scary costume troll youtube for gruesome
makeup tutorials and batter a group of
unlikable youth to death once more it
looks like spooky sleeper hit until dawn
might be getting BR DLC so let's stick
together for safety as we head into this
spooky gamespot news update according to
Destructoid sony is performing market
tests in the UK for a new piece of until
dawn dlc called rush of blood nope not
the call play album but a first-person
on-rails shooter designed to work for
PlayStation VR the site claims to
received an email which it says has been
verified and confirmed through a second
independent source that describes the
unsettling experience female explains
well you get transported around inside a
minecart it's very literally an on-rails
experience there are a few scattered
jumpscares as you'd expect but I played
the same 20-minute section twice once
with the DualShock 4 and once with the
dual move controllers so I'm hoping the
fall DLC is a lot more cut it out it
continues it starts off shooting targets
in the snow then moves toward a house
and as you get deeper into the house
enemies start appearing I believe they
were Wendigos we frequently reuse
jump-scare is the ghost from inside the
house in until dawn for you end up
fighting for the final area I've played
upon killing the ghost the game with
crash every time a game that keeps
crashing is of course a gamers worst
nightmare but wait what this until dawn
producer Pete Samuels previously said
fans hoping for a PlayStation VR version
of the game shouldn't hold their breath
as it is not happening PlayStation VR
cropped up in conversation a few times
during development but no we don't
expect it there'll be an edition of The
Untold own story to be playable in VR
anytime soon he explained not unless
somebody has a sudden rush of blood Oh
bead I see what you did there neither
Sony no supermassive games have
officially confirmed the dlc yet but it
sounds intriguing nontheless what do you
reckon ready for some more jump scares
and attractive but ultimately doomed
youth excited to see until dawn take on
VR or do you wish it was a more
traditional DLC offering let me know in
the comment section below or come find
me on twitter i am at Lucy James games
the mornin till dawn don't forget to
check out gamespot com and we'll see
time